تتحول الى المؤتمر الصحفي للمتحدث العسكري
الاسرائيلي هاجار
وفي معسكرات الوسطى في جنوبي قطاع غزه في
سان يونس وفي خربه خزع نحن نوائي القتال
في كل منطقه من المناطق وحسب القوات
المطلوبه كل منطقه هناك ميزات
مختلفه في القتال اليوم في خانيونس قتل
المخربون من
النخبه وايضا من هم من اخذ جزءا من
المذبحه في السابع من اكتوبر نحن نواصل
معالجه الانفاق تحت الارض والصواريخ وايضا
من ان نخفف من اطلاق الصواريخ باتجاه
اسرائيل
الليله كانت
هناك نحن نعمل حسب
ذلك القوات
تعمل القوا الت تعمل في الميدان وايضا
في الجنود
الاحتياط
نؤهل ونحن نعيد
الىها من القوات
الاحتياط سيعودون الى
العمل ويمكن من التخفيف من
الاقتصا واضا لتاكد من العوده الى العمل
والقوات هذا
يتعلق جيش الدفاع عليه ان يواصل
الحرب حسب ما هو المطلوب لهذه
القوات
المدان تعمل ليلا
نهارا
247 لم يك هناك مساعده في ميدان القتال
كهذه
ق الاحتياط هذه تعبير عن
قوه
جق
الامكانيات المطلوبه
منه الى جانب
ذ
نا
ايضا نضرب العدو وليس
بالمدنيين ونخفف الاضرار
بالمدنيين الشمال اليوم ايضا كان هناك
هجمات على قوات حزب
الله ايضا كان هناك هجوم على
القريه وحزب قول جنوب لبنان الى منطقه
قتال حزب الله مقابل حماس لا يه هو سكان
جنوب لبنان وايضا هو درع بشري بالنسبه له
سنواصل العمل في لبنان وفي كل مكان حزب
الله يقوم ضدنا بعمليات ارهابيه
منه اليوم بدات سنه السنه الدراسيه
الاكاديميه في الجامعات الكثير من قوات
الاحتياط مازالوا في الجبهه وهي فرصه
جديده لان نعرب عن تقديرنا لقوات الاحتياط
التفاني لهم
ولعائلاتهم نحن سنعمل كل شيء من اجل ان
نساعد الجامعات وان نمكنهم من العمل
والعوده الى البيت والعوده الى الدراسه
اسخ الاسبوع الاخير كان هناك وثيقه من
رئاسه الاركان تتعلق باصابه غير
داخل وما هو قرار رئيس الاركان بهذا
الش انا اعود على ما
اقوله يجب المهم ان نفهم
ذلك هناك من هناك تهديد على الجندي يمكن
ان
يموت ونحن نقوم بكل الامكانيات من الجو
والبر والبحر من اجل ان نوقف هذا النيران
وان لا يصاب جنودنا الى جانب هذا الامر ب
شبوع
وكل اسبوع واضا كل عده ايام نحن نوام
سياسه اطلاق النار هذا يعني ان هناك مناطق
هناك فيها
مدنيين وايضا نحن اصلينا مدنيين ونحن نعمل
بطريقه نقتل فيها العدو وليس
مدنيين نحن نعمل ذلك كل الوقت
باحترافيه
للجيش فيما يتعلق بالقوات نحن ايض احترافي
نحن نخطط الى الامام كل منطقه في غزه مثلا
خانيونس خانيونس هناك طريقه عمل
محدده نحن نعمل مع قوات خاصه قوات هندسيه
من فوق الارض وتحت الارض وفي اليوم قتلنا
عدد كبير من المخربين المخربين استسلموا
وايضا هناك اطار معين للحرب في هذه
المنطقه
ون القو
بطقه نصرح بعض القوات وان تكون القوات
دائما موائمه مما يمكننا من تحرير بعض
القوات
لعائلاتهم ونعود ويعود الى
الاقتر عجله
الاقتص وعليه نحتاج الى هذا هذا الامر
والنظر الى
الامام القا من ناحيه
الدورات المختلفه وفي المدرعات يعودون بعد
ان اخذوا الخبره في الحرب هذه مهمات جيش
الدفاع هل جيش الدفاع يمكن ان يقوم بعمليه
بريه في
رفح وسائل اعلام لا يمكن ان ننشر في وسائل
اعلام ما يعرفه العدو ما ياخذه
العدو
مراكز القوه لحماس في هذه
الحرب يجب ان نقوم ذلك باحترافيه وبذكاء
ولا نعطي العدو خططنا بهذا الشان معلومات
اقل
للعدو وفي وسائل الاعلام هذا هذا هو
مهم وهذه الامور لا يمكن ان نكشفها هنا
على هذه من هذه
المناص هنا هناك
حوائط في مناطق في مناطق المحيطه بقطاع
غزه ضد الصواريخ صواريخ المضاده
للمدرعات يعني ان السكان الجنوب لديهم
تهديد وتهديد
متواصل يجب ان نفحص
التفاصيل انا لا اريد ان اعطي معلومات لي
دقيقه يجب علينا ان نعيد الامن لسكان
الجنه ايضا يتعلق
بالحواجز وايضا نؤهل ونحسن
الام بشكل
حقيقي يكون هناك قوات وايضا حواجز معينه
وستائر
معينه لا اتحدث عن حائط معين
او هذا ايضا في الشمال والجنوب نبني
طريقه خاصه في الدفاع وان يكون هناك امن
خاص و نقنا لحضراتكم جانبا من المؤتمر
الصحفي اليومي الذي يعقده المتحدث باسم
الجيش الاسرائيلي دانيل هجار و